cinéma pour terminer avec un film qui
secoue un polar à la française dans
l'univers des convoyeurs de fonds avec
albert dupontel et jean dujardin le
convoyeur c'est le titre du film pascal
deschamps eric de la nuit vous avez déjà
subi des expériences comme un client
alexandre de mare et pourquoi en côte
hill à la vigilance cette petite société
de transport de fonds
victime de trois braquage sanglant six
mois écritoire un flic un voyou ou autre
chose encore sur les bas d'albert
dupontel est aussi novice que lui les
spectateurs un filtre le monde secret
des convoyeurs et jeunesse de la
sécurité souvent payés au smic se
transporter les millions il avait 35 ans
il était convoyeur de fulham
ce monde dont on ne parle guère les
rubriques faits divers ou sociale des
journaux payants de la société le 20e en
dix ans dis moi tu t'es déjà fracturé un
monde qui n'avait encore jamais été
abordé au cinéma c'est une profession
qui est bien particulière ça nécessite
de la discrétion - on est vu où on a vu
la télévision mieux c'est borloo ce
monde
le convoyeur en forcer les portes nous
faisant vivre au fil d'une intrigue à
tiroirs les épreuves de ces héros de
l'ombre sentir l'odeur de la poudre de
la peur et de la sueur une plongée
réussi le voilà ses blagues étaient les
derniers bons polars français que j'ai
vu moi s'il y avait un temps c'est alain
corneau ses choix des armes police
python 357 cyr et noir et je pense que
nicolas reprend les choses là encore ne
les a laissés en l'état
entre temps il ya une sorte d'
américanisation du polar français
hélas pour les domaines de courir tant
vu le film trouve que tout l'aspect
technique et très réaliste que celle des
attaques pour ceux qui les a vécus sont
prévôtale près vrai après évidemment que
les caractères du combat ailleurs elle
trouva mais fantasque comment ça c'est
du cinéma je fais les caractères des
personnages
dimanche le document terre et 3h taïwan
au boxon tableau d'une profession à
risque nicolas boukhrief a choisi la
couleur noire comme le genre du même nom
dans son film se réclament sans complexe
il tient le spectateur en haleine
jusqu'au dénouement final